tip I'll give you is I don't own a debit  card I've never owned one I've never  allowed my three sons to possess one  certainly and truly the worst Financial  tool ever given to the American Consumer  so a long time ago I asked myself a  simple question how would I remove 99.9  percent of my personal liability  like that so I use the safest form of  payment that exists on the face of the  Earth and that is a credit card credit  card B is a MasterCard American Express  Discover card not debit credit but  credit card every day of my life I spend  their money I don't spend my money my  money sits in a money market account it  earns interest actually nobody knows  where it is because it's not exposed  anybody to find it it's just sitting  there I go to the dry cleaner I give my  card I pick up the groceries I give my  card I put fuel in my boat on the  weekend I use my card